Every day the perishable goods are packed
up for transport.
Harvest Fresh supplies large supermarket chains
with vegetables grown on the company's own
fields and nearby farms.
Driver Lucky Thantheni is preparing his cargo.
Today he's taking it to a big warehouse in
Johannesburg.
The truck interior has to reach the required temperature before the delicate freight can be loaded.
Final instructions from the logistics manager.
The vegetables have to be kept cool at a constant temperature of 2.7 degrees Celsius
during the transport.
That will be checked on delivery.
"We need to make sure that everything is packed
correctly, is sealed correctly.
Because any, let's say, any heat and stuff
that comes into the vegetables, that are not
sealed correctly, not cooled properly, goes
to waste."
Refrigerated transport is important in a hot
country like South Africa.
This is one of the 13-thousand or so refrigerated
trucks in the country.
The fleet emits enormous amounts of greenhouse
gases.
The cargo area of most trucks is poorly insulated,
resulting in greater diesel fuel consumption
and spoiled produce.
South Africa's agency for standards, the SABS, wants to make refrigerated transports more climate-friendly.
A testing hall for refrigerated trucks was
recently opened here - the first on the African continent.
Germany's agency for international development
cooperation, the GIZ, supported the construction
of the hall by making contacts to companies
that operate similar testing facilities in Europe.
The technology had to be adapted for use in
South Africa.
Transport vehicles here are bigger and more
powerful than they are in Europe.
At the moment, only one out of five manufacturers
meets the minimum standards for insulation.
For the first time ever, the new facility
allows testers here to precisely determine
just how well the trucks are insulated.
There was no exact data available up to now.
"That gives a tool to all the manufactorers
to improve their insulation properly.
They can actually see their results in the
practical performance of the improvements
that they have made.
So that they can implement that into production.
With a lot of new trucks out there with better
insulation, we know we will use less diesel
to run the cooling systems.
Less diesel means less carbon emissions into
the atmosphere."
Every vehicle tested here gets an environmental
seal.
Before long, the seal will be required on
all vehicles that transport fresh produce abroad.
It tells how much fuel the vehicle needs for
refrigeration, and gives the values measured
by the temperature sensors in the testing
chamber.
Entering Johannesburg.
Lucky Thantheni has been on the road with
his vegetable truck for about an hour-and-a-half.
A special coolant helps maintain the low temperatures
in the cargo area.
Most refrigerated trucks use this coolant,
which contains a chemical that is harmful
to the environment.
Its impact on the atmosphere is 4-thousand
times greater than CO2.
The Transfrig company plans on switching to
another refrigerant.
The company has developed this prototype that
will soon hit the market.
It says it's the world's only cooling system
that uses propane, while minimizing the risk
of using the flammable substance.
"We use propane, because it is totally environmentally
friendly.
It does nothing to the OZONE layer.
Its carbon footprint is very small.
And that is why we chose propane.
And it's also very easily obtainable."
Using propane can sink coolant emissions by
a factor of a thousand.
Transfrig tested its prototype in this truck.
In the summer, it transports ice cream, cooled
to minus 25-degrees Celsius.
The company plans to produce five to ten further
propane-based cooling units here in the coming
months, and to test them on the road and put
the final touches on the new technology.
The cooling unit can be powered by a small
motor. That saves on fuel costs.
If everything works out as planned,
the conventional, environmentally harmful
coolant will no longer be used here.
The company wants to install the propane technology
in all refrigeration units for large, medium
and small vehicles.
"Then we will look at exporting to local African
markets - Zambia, Zimbabwe, Namibia, Botswana,
Mosambique.
We have a very good presence in all these
markets.
And once it's proven here we will it introduce
it into those markets."
Experts estimate that by 2030, South Africa
can reduce its CO2 emissions by 2 million
tons - alone through better insulation and
propane-based cooling units.
It's a first step toward making South Africa's
refrigerated transport climate-friendly.
And that is urgently needed to sustain the
sector's rapid growth.